le projet lancé en 2009 aux abords du
village de loisirs ne verra finalement
jamais le jour c'est ce qu'a dévoilé en
août france le propriétaire du terrain
dans un communiqué début août le
chantier était déjà à l'arrêt depuis de
longs mois en raison de difficultés au
niveau des devis la crise sanitaire a
fini d'enterrer le projet cette crise
sanitaire a affecté tout le secteur
culturel comme on le sait aussi donc
l'activité cinématographique et en
conjointement entre les deux sociétés
ils ont préféré abandonner ce projet
le complexe devait être composée de huit
salles et aurait dû accueillir entre 450
milles et 500 mille spectateurs par an
un véritable manque à gagner pour les
commerçants des alentours mais les
différents acteurs du projet ne compte
pas en rester là nous sommes encore trop
tôt pour savoir ce qui va se passer une
chose est sûre nous savons que nous de
france partenaire va nous proposer des
projets nous allons les étudier pour le
bien en fin de compte de notre ville
démord pas y un et de notre nos
commerçants au village des loisirs
reste désormais à attendre l'annoncé
d'un futur projet sur cette parcelle